the buzzword of this election campaign
was change island's economy maybe the
fastest growing in the EU but the people
here are struggling with soaring house
prices and years long waiting lists for
public health care the desire for change
is widely expected to oust the tea chef
Leo vodka of the fina Gale party who
nonetheless put on a brave face as he
cast his vote his main challenger maja
Martin of FINA foil also tried to look
relaxed as his polling station in a city
of talk but it seems the tide is turning
against both the main parties young
person growing up I have a lot of fears
about what the future is going to hold
for me with climate change and that's
going to affect my life in the future so
I hope that the greens can have a fair
amount of state and how Ireland shapes
its future I voted for alternatives to
feel again FINA fall so I didn't really
want to go independent but basically
just some kind of alternatives to the
status quo pray I can fail to get in
chin fain is the left wing nationalists
Republican Party previously regarded as
the political wing of the paramilitary
group the IRA now shedding those
associations and remoulding itself as a
progressive alternative today's very
important today's the day that the
people are in charge and every single
people have chose the stroke this
campaign that they won't change non
political factors may also influence the
outcome of this election it's the first
Saturday poll since 1918 storm winds are
sweeping across Ireland from the West
bringing gusts of 120 kilometres an hour
and slap-bang in the middle of polling
day a major rugby international just
gave still it gave notes so I saw Barry
this morning I've got a few jobs done
and I got bolding if David know that
this morning and have you voted already
know yeah Matt that game is more
important to voting I'm sorry I can't
believe they did it really mean
but it's important we vote counting of
the ballots won't start until Sunday
morning and the most likely outcome of
this election is a coalition government
if Shin fane chooses to enter that
coalition government it would be an
extraordinary outcome and could open the
door to a referendum for a united
Ireland and even if the party chooses to
stay in opposition the days of two-party
dominance here appear to be well and
truly over
Paul Brennan al Jazeera Dublin